[Musique]
oui si vous ne tenez pas à remporter le
titre de miss aspirine dès votre arrivée
sur la plage madame une seule solution
l'institut de beauté et le soleil
artificiel si vous n'avez pas droit aux
vacances cette année mais si vous êtes
vous aussi obsédé par l'idée bronzage à
tout prix obsession mondial sans
distinction de sexe ni de classe
rendez-vous à la même adresse lunettes
sombres pour protéger les yeux et
surtout les paupières soleil artificiel
à volonté
[Musique]
conduite au préalable d'un produit
filtrants vous attendrez patiemment et
peu vécu
[Musique]
côté pile ce que des faces que votre
peau père de madame sa blancheur
originelle
[Musique]
et c'est sans le moindre complexe
la démarche ferme harmonieuse et le
bikini comme arme de choc que vous venez
madame revendiquez votre place au soleil
revendications justifiées selon les
cameramen du magazine féminin qui ne
perdent pas un pouce de votre
installation
[Musique]
premier geste prudent sortir de votre
sac la bombe aérosol et vaporisez
soigneusement sur tout le corps le
produit solaire protecteur et hydratant
qui facilitera et maintiendra le hâle
celui-ci al'avantage de contenir à
produits isolants et le sable ne collera
pas à votre épiderme
[Musique]
il vaut mieux être couché cassis dit un
proverbe arabe
les jeux de plage ce n'est pas pour vous
la compétition du bronzage retient seuls
vos suffrages
[Musique]
s'il était vous ramène invariablement
dans votre maison de campagne ne fait
pas mauvaise tête à votre mari ne
soupirait pas après la côte d'azur et
prenez garde aux coups de soleil
cette crème solaire vous protégera
préventive elle est également curative
alors plage artificielle bord de l'eau
tonnelle champêtre quiberon sera le
mieux la compétition est ouverte
mesdames
à vous de jouer
[Musique]